The Joe Rogan experience.
The thing with the proud boys is the ruling elite are freedom men. You know,
it is a huge soy boy movement coming down at gun and put down a pipe, right?
I mean soy everywhere. If anybody's listening right now,
everybody that's listening right now, soy is bad for you. It's not good.
It is very bad. It's processed nonsense and estrogen. Oh yes. Well, it,
it uh, activates the phytoestrogens. No,
it has Actify phyto estrogens that, uh,
attacked the endocrine endocrine gland system.
Now when you look at the endocrine gland system of people in the spiritual
world,
endocrine gland system is the physical manifestation of the so called shockers
right now at the heart shock where what we have is called the thymus gland and
the diamonds. Glenn is the one that controls your sexual maturity.
And when you have an endocrine gland disruptor,
your sexual maturity is affected.
So a man who would ordinarily, like women now likes,
you see what I'm saying?
But wouldn't you have to have massive quantities of soy for that take place?
That's that subjective based upon your biological structure.
I always think of it as more as like a fun thing to say. I don't think you know,
well, here's a total fool. You turn into a bitch. Well, here's the thing,
you can't go in a grocery store and find something that doesn't have soy.
When you go look at your cheeses or your crackers, it wasn't say soy lecithin,
soy and everything. So yeah, you were right. Uh,
they use it as phyllo for some meats. So the whole vegan movement, right?
You go when you go get your, your, your, your burger burger. Yeah. Right? Uh,
a lot of these burgers are soy-based. A lot of them are plant-based for sure.
Plant-based oils, right? But so it's not good for you. Right?
And then you also look at the links between soy and cancer,
but that's a whole nother story.
But when you have something that's disrupting your so-called chorus,
you can see how you can start affecting an entire population of people, right?
You start affecting their development at an early age. And then, you know,
you got these men who are, uh, acting like women who can't even, you know,
control their wives. You got some men out here that uh,
let another man sleep with their girlfriend. Right.
And I don't know about her here. Well, you're saying out here,
well what I say out here, I mean it's everywhere,
but just people just kinky in the weird shit.
Well no, you don't think so? No. Wait, what do you think it is?
I think it's pushed. I think a [inaudible] is highly pushed. Yeah. By who?
The ruling elite ruling class. I want to say really,
because they're not elite to sit around and go, you know what we need to do?
We need to push the Boucher. Well, when you look at, uh, the degradation of, uh,
Russia, right? Um, before the Bolshevik revolution,
what they do is they come in first, uh, with alcohol, right?
So they purchase your hops and your barley and he produced alcohol.
Then what they do is they sell the alcohol to the farmer on credit.
Cause he ain't got no money. Right. Cause he'd been drunk.
He hasn't been producing a crop. Psyche should, he falls into credit.
He falls into debt when he falls into the debt. He's now a slave to the land.
He wants old now and I can sell, uh,
whatever I want to this population or give this population whatever I want
because they are now technically my sleeve.
But in order to rule a nation of people,
you have to destroy morality. You have to destroy integrity.
So you feed them drugs, alcohol and sex,
and then tear apart the family.
But do you think that that's just a natural progression of people's slovenly
instincts or do you think that some sort of a grand plan will have a slovenly
instinct? Some people do. Yeah.
I think some people are lazy and some people are weak and some people are greedy
and some people just, they lean towards,
they lean towards just pleasure without sacrifice and discipline because it's
easy and they just lay in bed and jerk off.
I don't think anybody's telling them,
I don't think there's any sinister government manipulating their strings that
makes them watch porn all day. I think they just, yeah, it actually, you know,
Instagram is a gateway to porn. Instagram.
You can't go on Instagram without looking at some booty, right? Yeah.
But it's also a gateway to sunsets and people's kids and muscle cars and come,
Joe, cool shit. By going on Instagram, it has sunset.
People are going to Instagram and look at booty. There's a lot of that.
No dog yoga community has went from, Hey,
check out my Bakasana to check out my backside pants.
Right. A lot of yoga pants, pics, booty, booty, booty.
Just booty alone is an industry. It is a giant industry. Instagram. Yeah.
So what happens is you wake up in the morning, you check your notifications,
then your homie tags you. Oh, look at this chick DePaul right now.
You have an erection. What's the first thing you do? You like, ah,
let me go to my browser, open an incognito browser and hit PornHub. Boom.
Now you outta here. Right now your day's done. You just depleted your energy.
Right? And this coming out in my book where I talk about, you know,
why you sent our golf and all that stuff, but you right,
that you shouldn't jerk off. Yeah. Yeah. Never a well, there's a calculation.
You have a jerk-off algorithm yet is a jerk off algorithm. Uh,
it's created by the tower, the tower, sta sexology.
And I think it's your age times to know your age divided by two times 100.
I forget what it is. It's in my book. I can't remember it. Uh,
but I got it from the Tao. Right. Which is why I don't have it memorized.
Time point. It's age times 0.2 things, age times, 0.2. Um,
and then it'll tell you how many days. Right? So at my age, I'm 38 now my age,
it's about seven and a half days between ejaculation to mean to maintain who I
am. Really? Yeah. And damn. Yes.
So a main strength is his balls, right? Right.
Every time you deplete yourself, you're not the same man anymore.
You lose your superpowers. Now,
when you lose your superpowers to some, you know, IgG model,
it's not even worthy.
Your orgasm doesn't feel the same as a natural interaction with a woman,
right. You know what I mean? True. So you're, you're wasting your superpower on,
on, on like a fictional fantasy,
so you're wasting a percentage of your vital energy, your,
your vital energy as well as the proteins and minerals and zinc and magnesium
and all that stuff that you know is lost. Yeah,
I think it's equivalent to like two New York strip steaks, eggs,
oranges and apples or something like that. Oh yes. A lot of vitamins.
This is why I have a woman on the size of the loads you shoot though. Know? Oh,
ladies should swallow. Whoa. Jesus ladies. I'm sorry.
That's why you should ingest it.
If the man is healthy because it's a, it's a full meal. It's a full meal.
It's a full meal of nutrients that a man loses.
There's a vial available that way. I wonder if anyone has done studies.
I bet they have a bet people have done like nutrition slash load studies.
Probably a startup out there like trying to do this right now.
Calculate it into an app.
Where's this conversation going now? What are we talking about?
Manipulating you, turning you into a soy boy? [inaudible] it's you,
you think does actual this, this is where we differ.
You think there's actual manipulation taking place?
I think it's just natural instincts and then I think that people see it around
them and then they cater to those natural instincts and then they support those
natural instincts.
But I think people have a natural instinct to be undisciplined and lazy and just
gratuitous and you know,
dive into pleasure before sacrifice and commitment.
And so we make an excuses for not making excuses. I think it's a, uh,
also the softness of the world we live in. Oh yeah. I mean,
we live in this incredibly easy to get buy in world, right? You know,
where the poor people are fat. Yeah.
There's never been a time in history where poor people are fat. Yeah. Yeah.
That, that comes down to the actual food so-called. It's certainly,
that is certainly the food is garbage, but it's also that
there's this strange lack of discipline because it's not, it's not necessary.
I have to do is just show up to your job,
put in the least amount of effort you can without getting fired.
And you can exist. That didn't,
that didn't happen in the wild world when people are hunters and gatherers of
you didn't put 100% effort. If you didn't really struggle,
you didn't make it and you weren't a benefit to the tribe and they kicked your
ass out and you got eaten. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's how it's supposed to be.
I do agree with that. Yeah. I do agree with that. Um, discipline is, is,
you know what we have to demand from people, you know? Um,
but you know, your, your culture has to recognize the Boucherie and, and,
and shun it and ban it and say like, Hey, you know, we don't want this here.
You know, um, uh,
porn is readily available on Twitter and watch it right in your feet.
Sometimes I'm scrolling my feet.
I know that's a weird thing about Twitter, isn't it? That it's a giant platform,
but they allow porn. Yeah. So, you know, when I had Jack on with Tim Poole,
and I think Tim Poole didn't even know that porn was legal on it. Yeah.
I showed up. Yeah. I have found that a little bit of information,
I don't know how accurate pools Twitter use. No.
On the ejaculation frequency recommended by the towels.
It said the most respected of the town theorist sun SIM Meow [inaudible] quoted
above recommends ejaculations no more than once every 20 days for men over 50
cheeses and no more than once every hundred days for men over 60 would that I
should be dead. Okay. And it has to do with it says no energy.
How am I getting everything done?
You're getting age retarding hormones as you're about to ejaculate and then
there's a level you want to keep before you ejaculate.
So balance what you're before you excrete the hormones. That's what it's saying.
So tantra quick, supposed to come and turn.
There's a level you can like optimize yourself in Jackie [inaudible],
they call it those people out of their fucking minds.
I'm trying to get rid of this shit. I,
I've always said that it helps you think because too many times with a man your,
your mind is clouded by sexual desire.
If you could just jerk off and then you can think clearly. I always tell him,
I said a bit about it. I say jerk off first, then think about it.
Like if you jerk off and then you want to call a girl,
it's because you love her.
You're not just trying to fuck you actually like her as a human being.
You want to be around her.
You don't just be one to want to be around him for sex.
You actually really love her. Yeah. I think there's a level of discipline,
right? So, um, yeah. If you're about to make that,
that risky text message, yeah.
You might want to shoot your low and recessive. That's what I'm talking about.
What though? I'm going to watch him fucking documentary, put that phone down.
But that's Ford. Undisciplined man. Yes. Right.
The man's going to say, no, I'm not going to send this thirst trap. You know,
uh, this, this thirsty comment.
I'm going to stay disciplined in who I am because in order to get the woman I
have to stay away from the woman, you know,
in order to get the woman I have to stay away from the woman. Yeah. And, and,
and, and, and keeping your, you're at your vital man.
Energy for me keeps me like on edge.
Like I'm always like an animal, you know what I mean? Um,
because I want to release, you see what I'm saying? So, um,
what I do is I'll work up that energy and then channel it into work.
Hmm. I'll just immediately
pull my laptop out. Just bang out.
Cause it's like that frustration here and then you just,
you got to release it that way. Or I'll go running, I'll go work out.
But when I get around women, what a full sec.
Oh, I'm not the same as when I'm empty. Yes. And they see,
you can see the difference in how they attracted you. You sit up different,
your chest pokes out.
When you're around other men you're like a little bit more edgy. Yeah, yeah.
You know what I mean? And you blow your load, you're kind of like chilled out.
Yay. Non competitive. Noncompetitive. Yes.
You hold on to that. Like fighters, you know how to fight the fight.
Mike Tyson never did that. Mike Tyson said, no,
I always lied to calm with much as possible fun and not distracted and just
shoot his loads and a beat the fuck out of everybody,
but I think Mike had a lot of extra loads. I think if you had a guess,
it's level. He was just the ultra man. You know there was,
it was not a regular man.
A research published by the U S national library of medicine and national
institutes of health found that after seven days of not ejaculate,
men's testosterone levels reached 145.7% of the baseline.
Damn.
Interesting thing is that they didn't observe significant fluctuations from the
baseline on days two through five.
The research also showed that the peak levels were at day seven. Yeah,
risks Dow, it's actually Dow by the way. It's T a. O. It's a,
it's you say it as Dow,
the Dow of G condo risks of too frequent ejaculation.
When sex is performed with the recommended Dow frequency,
it becomes an inexhaustible source of energy, like a well that never runs dry.
However,
when ejaculations frequency exceeds the capacity of the body to fully replenish,
the seamen man could experience chronic fatigue, low resistance,
loss of sex drive, loss of focus, and irritability.
Longterm excessive ejaculation can cause chronic low zinc conditions,
which can cause chronic fatigue, mental confusion,
and significant loss of sexual drive.
But what have you with a freak like that girl will,
Harris was talking about my friend will house was in here the other day and he
was saying any human he needs to meet these girls and explore, see, Oh,
it's also considered harmful to ejaculate when ill drunk or go Gorge with food.
Whoa. Here's the next, the next line. Oh which one?
Ejaculation control and discipline is not to be confused with a frequency of
sex. There are significant physiologic fizz.
What's that word? Physiological. There's supposed to be a period there.
Oh physiologic. Again, therapeutic benefits to having sex.
Frequent sex intercourse maintains a man's interest in the acts as well as his
capacity to continue indefinitely until his partner is fully satisfied.
So they're saying fuck, but don't come. Yes,
those people out of that fucking mind. I come every time I fuck yo.
I, I used to uh, try and get rid of this stuff. I used to fuck in three words.
I used to fuck with girls heads like that. We would not come. Yeah. Real.
They start crying. Wow. I had a girl like straight down and break up cry.
I can't please you. Is it me? Is it? Nah. I'm just like, no.
I just wanted you to be happy. How you feel? I feel good. Good.
Then I go and I hit the laptop and it just, Oh really?
Oh kitty let it cause like nature wants them to get you to come.
Yes. Women only respected discipline, man. You don't want,
it's true. Once a woman can drop your defenses,
she's no longer attracted to you. If she can control you,
she's not attracted to you. A woman wants a man she could chase.
In my book I talk about how women are the apex predator.
They're the ones that chase after sex. I mean they can have sex endlessly,
right? Once we know it's like we're pretty much done. Like, I mean,
give me a couple of minutes to recharge, but it could keep going.
You see what I'm saying? So they're, you know, technically like, you know,
freaks or whatever.
But just because she's undisciplined and her sexual energy doesn't mean you have
to be.
And if she feels like she has to go outside of the relationship to go get her
fixed, that's the one hood that has nothing to do with you.
Your aspirations as a man are higher than sex.
A woman's role is to create life and support the man.
The man's role is to create the, the, the,
the afforded in the future of, of humanity. You know,
building things and innovating.
And it's true that a woman is not attracted to a guy without discipline.
Like men are lazy and weak, dah, dah, dah. The giant turnoff to a woman.
But if a woman is hot, she could be pretty lazy. Absolutely.
They are the laziest people don't care. Mendo I don't care if a girl's lazy,
she's hot. Well, long as her body holds up well, she can get to the gym.
I used to make girls work to get me, man. Really? Yeah. Like, you know,
I would say I'm, you know, I'm working on this project, you know,
I'm going to send a spreadsheet over. I need you to go organize it.
And if she'd say no, I'd just be like, all right,
well you're worthless to my life. Right. I need,
I need someone that's going to build with me. Right.
What if she's building on her own shit? Fuck her shit.
Go Pilcher shit. You know, if you need help, I'll help you. But you know,
she want to partner. Yeah. Want just a lover. That's what you're saying. No,
no. You want someone to help you? No. I want her to prove her worth. Whoa.
She gotta be worried to get me like, you know,
it's easy to get a girl then he's gonna get them. Good man. You know,
you only gonna find one Hotep Jesus in your life.
I could find a ton of you showed him. Wow.
You everywhere on Instagram after Joe Rogan is going to be,
they going to be everywhere.
So now some would say that that's a sexist generalization.
Sure. I don't care what the Donald care like we can have that conversation.
I bring you in your platform. We can talk and I'll, you know,
if you want to call it sexist, it is what it is.
Have you ever had a conversation with like a radical feminist about this kind of
thinking? Oh they won't talk to me. They all blocked me.
They block the all black, you know the whole,
the whole black left feminists.
The reason why he blocked me is cause they can't beat me. Right.
When we have conversations,
I'm so objective that it's too dangerous for them to engage with me. How so?
Cause I'll be like, it's sexist. Yes. And so let's,
let's continue the conversation and then that's where they don't want to go.
Cause then they're going to have to provide reinforcement and evidence and
you're dealing with an educated man and I'm going to come with my evidence and
facts so you don't have a problem being sexist. That's what the problem is.
Because if someone calls you sexist and you go, yeah, yeah, I'm sexist.
Yeah it is. What is this? It's like somebody called me racist or whatever.
I don't care what your opinion is.
I don't care about these isms that you create. I understand nature.
I understand myself.
[inaudible].